well it's been a whirlwind day here in
Westminster so let's get Labor's take
now because we are now joined by Jim
McMahon who is the party Shadow
environment food and Rural Affairs
secretary thanks for being with us well
let's start with Boris Johnson uh shall
we what do you make of the evidence
I think anybody seeing the uh the
performance and it was a performance uh
in Parliament today I think we'll be
left feeling quite frustrated because
for me this can't be viewed for how we
feel today how we live our lives today
we're free today we can see our friends
and family today we can socialize today
if we have loved ones and Care Homes we
can see them today that wasn't what was
happening when Boris Johnson was
breaking the rules and holding their
Partners in Downing Street and I think
his lack of Emperor and understanding
about what people really went through
for those sacrifices I think for me is
the biggest mistake he has made in that
representation
was there a blurring of the lines though
for people who were allowed within the
rules to work together who were working
in stressful environments who might have
had a glass of wine or a beer at the end
of a day's work when we saw of course
which I know a lot of people about
social media are flagging up kirst armor
with a beer in Durham as well and that's
what the rules allowed for the rules
were that's what he was saying though as
well Boris Johnson says the guidance was
followed well not particularly because
this was about what you could do that
avoided unnecessary contact we were all
asked to keep a two meters or if not at
least a meter we're all asked to undergo
changes to our daily routines the
difference here and people do make the
equivalent in the way that you've said
first of all Kirsten didn't break the
rules it's pretty clear that he's a rule
maker not a rule breaker and that was
found during the the inquiry of Honduran
police but they were away staying away
for work purposes Boris Johnson and the
staff who worked in down industry were
there as their office and they were
having parties birthday parties Kate was
brought in they literally went to Tesco
was say with our suitcases bringing
in bottles of wine that wasn't what was
happening in Care Homes it wasn't
happening in hospital Awards and that's
what we've got to compare it to and it
was Boris Johnson you know uh in the
evening at the podium saying to people
listen this is really important we need
to stay at home we need to save lives
and we need to protect the NHS and
people did that they made the sacrifices
I know what my family went through in
terms of making sacrifices not seeing
each other I've heard your family go
through them we're not being able to
celebrate birthdays not being able to
meet on the anniversary of the debt of
passing away of a grandparent the times
when you would come together as a family
to support each other uh weren't there
and in a way we were the lucky ones we
didn't have an elderly person in a care
home but if we did imagine the rents
that you would feel today watching that
performance in Parliament when
potentially somebody that you love that
you cared for that raised you uh in a
care home you weren't able to see in the
final moments because you made the
sacrifice because you were asked to for
the national interest and Boris Johnson
didn't do that I just think he's told
deaf to wear the public are on this do
you think that some people might be
looking at this and thinking look
it's time to move on now and you know
Boris Johnson has been fined by police
we've been all through all this before
people's and made up their minds on this
already why are we just going over the
same ground well I think integrity and
politics really matters I don't buy the
argument at all that all politicians are
the same that we're all in it for
ourselves the poor behavior in the way
that we're seeing and selfish behavior
is normal and should be accepted I think
the bar should be high and the public
have a right to for it to be high I
think the danger in what we're seeing in
Parliament is being kind of dragged into
the gutter allows him to say but
everyone was doing it everyone was
breaking the rules you know I know that
everyone was at it everyone was not at
it I know people who work in the NHS and
all people that work in Care Homes I
know people that work for local councils
I know people right across the industry
in retail and other places who stuck to
the rules because they were asked to and
they realized that there was a lot of
stake here like people would die in the
pandemic was ripping through society and
people that we cared about were being
lost that was the the context we can't
view what's going on today through
today's context where we live in our
lives in a in a Freer way in terms of
should we just move on uh which is a you
know a question that I've seen being
asked I think accountability matters and
an inquiry by its nature is backward
looking that's what inquiry does and for
a political accountability it's
important that the prime minister of the
day who has so much of the nation is
held to account for the rules that he
set okay well we're here we heard from
Boris Johnson today we'll hear more I'm
sure as that goes on he says of course
that he did follow the rules and he
didn't willfully or intentionally
mislead Parliament um Keen to ask about
Richard cnx tax Affairs as well because
he has published those uh today it shows
what I guess we knew already that he's a
wealthy individual does that matter it
doesn't matter there's welfare uh in
fact I you know fair play for somebody
who's done well and who earns that kind
of money it doesn't mean he isn't
experiencing the cost of living crisis
in the way that many of us are and I
think a bit more understanding from the
Prime Minister and the chancellor about
the everyday struggles that people are
facing I think would go a long way to
rebuilding trustwoman I think most MPS
are relatively wealthy if you look at I
know they're different levels but if you
look at the rest of the country well I
mean I left school at 15 I've worked in
many of the jobs that my constituents
work in and I know what it's like to
struggle and not be able to pay bills
and make the choices about who in the
family uh I know what it's like to
struggle and that by the way was in very
different circumstances we had family
tax credits that helped us I see people
today that are really struggling to make
ends meet on a government that isn't
providing the support that's needed you
know Labor's made calls for for instance
the non-dom tax status to be changed
we've made calls for the one percent uh
pension uh break that's currently being
put through that's costing a billion
pound not to be prioritized in favor of
support for working people and the Prime
Minister hasn't done that so it's not
about his personal wealth we knew that
he was well off it was about what does
he understand the real life lived
experience of working people in Britain
and I think the evidence says from the
budget that he just doesn't what about
capital gains tax talking about tax
policy because what these tax Affairs do
also show is that the amounts of tax
that you pay a through Capital contains
cancer of course at substantially lower
rate to income tax is that fair well I
think we are going to have to review of
how tax in the UK is balanced whether
it's right and fair and proportionate
and whether it's equity for people
regardless of their work status uh
Rachel Reeves uh of course will be
bringing forward with those plans as we
get closer to the election there'll be
more say on that but what we said for
this budget is that we can do far more
on non-dom tax status we can do far more
on the one percent he'll benefit from
the pension break to help working people
today